everybody what is going on welcome to
another Python with OpenGL and PI OpenGL
and PI game tutorial video this video
we're just gonna be building on the last
one and beginning to create our object
avoidance games so right now a couple of
problems we have is this cube starts in
the same place every time also we want
to be able to like press and hold our
arrow key so this is pretty typical pi
game code here as far as that's
concerned
so let's go ahead and make those
necessary changes now so the first thing
we want is one we want the cube to start
at like a random location so we know
we're going to need import random now
we're just going to come down here and
the first thing that we'll go ahead and
do is since we're we're rerunning main
every time what we can do to make the
cube appear to be you know coming at us
randomly really simply could be
something like this we could just say a
random dot R and range 0 earth actually
negative 5 to 5 and then do the exact
same thing again so that would be to the
creation of the X variable and then
again we do the same thing for the Y and
that will start us in a random place
every time so we can go ahead and
visualize that really quick so there's
the cube there now it's down there
I've got another one there we would have
hit that one there another one there but
even with this you can see how it's
absolutely necessary that we would
probably need to have more than one cube
but the other thing that we're having
problems with is that we have to tapping
or key we want to be able to hold the
key and old a maneuver so doing that
we've covered before but we'll go ahead
and throw that into this video as well
so first of all we need to specify some
simple beginning numbers here so we'll
say X move equals 0 Y move equals 0 easy
enough and then we'll come down here and
instead of you know calling this stuff
we're gonna move in I think we'll keep
we'll do point threes probably
but instead of that we're going to say X
move equals 0.3 here so a key left means
we're hitting the left key there so 0.3
and then over here we'll just copy this
and paste it right here and say negative
0.3
then we'll go ahead and do the exact
same thing here so the up arrow we want
to go ahead and do Y move equals
negative 3 and then we'll do the same
thing down here we would say Y move
equals 3 then when we're all done well
now we actually need to have key ups as
well so um there's a couple of ways that
we could do this we could just do it
really easily
we'll just copy that paste and instead
of key down we'll do key up and then it
would be x equals 0 but mmm I guess
we'll just what we'll do is we'll take
this move it up here or event equals
execute X move equals 0 and then same
thing again here or when K Y move equals
0 and that should do it so now if you
press and hold the key our our move will
hold there and if you release it the
move will stop so let us now we'll
basically modify this translate down
here so you would just say X move wyman
right so you could just add an X
underscore move and then over here add
in Y underscore move save and run that
and now we're holding a position now of
course there's a there's one major
problem with that as if is you're still
holding it like because mean is
restarting every time while we move
really quick there do we do three
possibly what do we do there that's too
fast
yeah we did a whole number okay zero
point three and then zero point three
that was very fast okay so anyway so
obviously we've got a couple of things
that we're not too happy with this is
really just meant to be a really simple
working version of kind of what we had
before where there's just one block but
obviously this is an ideal so we're
gonna have to change a lot of stuff here
but anyway what we want is many blocks
we want that key to hold we want them to
be random the problem with many blocks
that are random is the generation of
those blocks having them there and then
one other final problem that we have
down the road is say you put a bunch of
blocks on this screen and you just hold
the left key or something you're going
to avoid every single block okay so you
need to have some blocks that are even
off the screen entirely or you could
have like walls or something like that
that keeps the player in this specific
area but I kind of like the idea of like
infinity you've write down all the sides
so that's probably where we're gonna
we're going to go with this game but
anyway that presents some calculation
and really processing issues that we'll
have to tackle so anyways that's it for
this video if you guys have any
questions or comments on this video feel
free to leave them below otherwise as
always thank you for watching thanks for
all the support in the subscriptions and
till next time